all right let's get into audience
questions for the week very relevant and
prescient questions today the first is
hey David could so-called rhinos be
better allies for removing Trump than
the never Biden people in November of
2020 rhinos are Republicans in name only
okay I think that thinking that is sort
of defeatist tanned I'm gonna tell you
why there is no doubt that there is a
Republican movement that hates Trump and
wants to remove him this includes people
like George Conway the husband of Trump
advisor Kellyanne Conway this includes
people like you know the Steve Schmidt
is an advisor and Rick Wilson who I've
interviewed on the show these are
Republican strategist types who don't
like Trump and want to see him removed
now the question about allies could be
interpreted two ways number one is just
like in the sheer numbers of it do I
think there will be more Republicans who
abandoned Trump and vote Biden then the
number of never Biden people who would
normally be Democratic voters but are
going to either not vote or vote third
party or vote for Donald Trump I think
the answer is no I mean listen every
every election there is abandonment if
you look at 2008 there were a bunch of
people who voted for Hillary in the
Democratic primary and then voted for
John McCain in 2016 you saw some Bernie
primary voters who abandoned Hillary
abandoned the party so to speak and
voted for Trump it was actually a
smaller number than the number that did
the abandonment in 2008 and went to
McCain every election you have that I
don't think the numbers actually going
to be that big and I know that the the
never Biden movement is very very loud
online but you have to understand that
there's a lot of things that are very
very loud online and it turns out that
they don't really reflect reality as
closely as we might imagine or we might
even hope the Bernie run is an example
of that it's so much online activity and
then Bernie lost three consecutive super
Tuesday's only the last of by that I
mean the three Tuesday's in March that
have a bunch of elections only the last
one was even
moderately affected by the coronavirus
and there's no particular reason to
believe that that actually hurt Bernie
more than it hurt Biden so I don't
actually think that the never Biden
movement is going to be what prevents
Biden from winning I think that there is
no question though that we should
welcome Republicans who are not going to
vote Trump once Trump's out whoever the
next president is either Biden in in
winning in November or some other
Democrat winning four years from now at
some point those Republicans are going
to be back to disagreeing with us on
most policy and that's it so the idea of
them being allies anybody who doesn't
vote for Trump votes for Biden right any
one of those votes helps remove Donald
Trump and we'll take it and we love it
and it's all fantastic the more people
that realize that this guy is a lethal
menace the better and more efficiently
that we can remove him but I worry about
the hostility of saying man some of
these Republicans are better allies than
the never Biden people we it's not one
or the other we need everybody and there
are reasons why people might be
Republicans and not want Trump that
would be completely unaligned with our
values we might be not really a small
government conservative they hate that
he did the stimulus like there's people
that are mad at Trump on the right
because he did the coronavirus stimulus
coronavirus stimulus wasn't big enough I
mean okay if they don't want to vote
Trump in November because of it and
they're gonna help Biden win by one vote
each I'll take it but the reason they
disagree with Trump might be completely
not in line with our values
so everybody's an ally who helps remove
Trump but the idea that we want to start
shaming never Abidin people by saying
these rhinos are even better allies for
us I don't think it's a good idea I
don't think it's pragmatic I don't think
it's based in the facts either one of
our sponsors today is VIN Chara watches
giving you 15% off your entire order
when you go to david pakman.com slash
watch don't pay thousands of dollars for
a high-quality watch that looks great
because you don't have to all of in
Cera's watches are made with high end
materials masterfully built and they
look like something you'd spend a ton of
money on but ever even Chara watch
ranges from about a hundred and fifty to
three hundred bucks I went over to their
website and picked out the bellwether in
silver and white really nice elegant
look and a lot of people asked me
where's the watch from really really
great look totally different they also
sent me the altitude in matte black and
red a much more rugged view of what a
watch can look like really liked it as
well as well as the athletic strap it's
a new year it's a new decade it's time
to re-establish your style add something
new to your look and a high-quality
watch is the perfect way to do that you
can get 15% off inch arrows entire
collection when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch